j'ai connu donc le parlement 489 c'était
un parlement on pourrait travailler plus
facilement quand vous avez des
commissions à 130 120 s'apprendre
députés y a pas trahi réel en plus
encore aujourd'hui quand vous êtes dans
un système où comme vous avez des comme
les commissions son public
les parlementaires après sont dans ces
espèces de classification de mon député
ou je ne sais quoi la toutoute sait tous
et tous ces sites qui donc que d'écouter
donc plus donc les donc comme les
notations sont en fonction du nombre
d'interventions donc ils sentent obligés
j'ai vite eu tout ça donc je le sais
d'intervenir pour montrer que raymond
est faible à la baisse du mois je suis
favorable pour qu'il y ait des réunions
de commissions qu'ils soient des plus
constructif possible on puisse vraiment
faire la loi et deuxièmement pardon
maintenant qu'il ya plus de cumul des
mandats il n'y a absolument pas de
responsabilité pour 510 est ce que nous
qu'on peut que ravir les palais jusqu'à
combien non mais quatre ça c'est bien
moi j'ai toujours proposé 420 drac est
très bien il faut bien que nos
compatriotes comprennent que derrière ça
on n'est pas dans une casse où on peut
intervenir à tout moment
le débat parlementaire est extrêmement
codifié il ya un parlementaire par
groupe et donc vous avez des députés qui
ne sont même pas ne peuvent pas dans
l'hémicycle intervenir pour apporter une
contribution une solution en limite le
droit d'amendement
non déjà il a été limité suffisamment
comme ça mais on a 400 députés si on a
moins de sénateurs on s'en portera pas
plus mal non plus et donc ça c'est le
premier chant et sur la proportionnelle
graal alors on y arrive effectivement
combien déboursant 25 par an comme le
préconise vous examinez de goody
à combien le grinch parce que propose
l'écurie ça m'est égal
mais ce que je sais c'est qu'il va alors
on est d'accord et donc ce que ce qu'il
faut c'est suffisamment de
parlementaires sinon ça n'a pas de sens
il faut que nos compatriotes comprennent
là aussi que si ces dix ou si c'est 15
si vous êtes un parti politique qui fait
15% aux 18% enfin peu importe vous allez
avoir combien de députés deux trois
quatre cinq
est ce qu'avec deux trois quatre ou cinq
parlementaires une formation politique
qui fait 15 ou 20 % est en capacité
d'avoir une expression politique
suffisant non donc il est donc il faut
que derrière ça ya la capacité pour des
formation politique il ne gagne pas de
sièges au scrutin majoritaire d'avoir un
groupe parlementaire
parce qu'ici a pas de groupe
parlementaire ya pas d'expression
politique et si ya pas d expression
politique
on a fait une proportionnelle pour rien
ce pour permettre à quelques leader d'un
parti politique de rentrée au parlement
vous la belle affaire et donc c'est pas
ça le sujet le sujet c'est ferran soeur
qu'il y ait des familles politiques pour
lesquelles je n'ai aucun point aucun
point commun ya aucun point commun avec
le front national très bien mais le
front national doit être présent à
l'assemblée nationale c'est très simple
oui il est là les vins un niveau alors
après une étude de terrain il ya 125
pour dia la symbolique ya recettes ouais
y'a la recette
il n'y a pas simplement le fait
d'afficher sait comment font les choses
asie 6 étoiles arabes ont alors répartie
de santé je vois que vous je vois que
vous avez tout ça en tête
mais moi je pense que cette
proportionnelle elle doit être
correctives si le chiffre est bas c'est
à dire qu'il ne doit pas s'adresser à
ceux qui auraient fait beaucoup plus que
si ça n'avait tech à la proportionnelle
il faut inventer en quelques sortes un
système à l'allemande ou il ya un
correctif entre le scrutin majoritaire
tel qu'il a donné des résultats et le
scrutin proportionnel s'il avait été
complètement impliqué et parce que c'est
c'est une question de démocratie si on
veut que le parlement c'est un lieu de
débat de référence
il faut que les grands mouvements
politiques du pays soient représentés il
ya un troisième point c'est le non cumul
des mandats dans le temps des élus et
notamment des élus locaux celui-là il
fait bondir la ouate en particulier la
droite sénatoriale
et ben moi aussi vous aussi pourquoi
vous que vous vous estimez pas légitime
la demande de certains mais pourquoi
c'est pourquoi voudriez vous qu un maire
qui fait son boulot mais disent monsieur
rentrez chez vous en vertu de quoi les
petites communes ne sont pas concernés
mère et moi ça m'embête 3005 moi j'ai
jugé pardon j'ai jugé
je suis fier à bras j'ai été maire
pendant 20 ans ma commune je pense
l'avoir transformé en profondeur je
faisais des scores dithyrambiques qui à
chaque élection bien plus que ce que
représentait ma famille politique
en vertu de quoi on aura empêché les
habitants de la commune de continuer à
élire des délires leur mère s'il le
souhaitait je comprends pas cette
histoire là pour les consulter les
rouges pour vour le parlement je suis
d'accord ok trois mandats c'est un petit
mot